misha first of all so nice getting to
talk to you congratulations on winning
big brother how are you feeling right
now
uh it's still surreal i'm just trying to
take it all in i can't believe that i
did that but i managed to get through
that what a crazy journey
crazy i i can imagine did you even have
any feeling coming into this house that
you were gonna win
i always picture myself winning and and
visualize that and how i was gonna get
to the end of it but to be honest i'm
like well the odds are definitely
against me and and i was also thinking
like this is not just about winning
competitions there is an element of this
game i cannot control and i never
thought my social game was gonna be my
strong point i mean i'm not a recluse
but i am not a social butterfly by any
means and i was a little worried about
that part of it so um
yeah here we are
well congratulations uh do you have any
plans with how uh you're gonna spend
this money
well first and foremost i have to spoil
my children who have been without mommy
for a month so that's my first
prerogative is to take them toy shopping
and just let them enjoy themselves and
enjoy my time with them until they're
sick of me
and
it's a little if we can slide in a short
little family vacation there and um
well
yeah i think i would want to put that
money towards fixing up
making our house like better and someday
marrying my amazing fiance
oh well that sounds pretty good to me
all those things sound amazing all right
so let's talk about the game a little
bit did you expect
todrick to only get one vote
no i was very blindsided by that um i
think i have a lot to go back and review
and try to like see the other side of
the coin because one thing i do know as
a fighter is it's very different when
you're in it in the octagon and you're
fighting as opposed to watching it from
the outside and i feel like i need to
gain both perspectives yeah so how were
how surprised were you by the jury's
reaction to todd rick and how we played
the game
very very surprised um i really didn't
see it coming and i think i was
very naive in all of it really like the
way that i entered the game lack of
preparedness on my part and just not
really looking at things in a in a
different light or big picture but
oh my gosh it's such a weird
circumstance and pressure cooker so
i think that
you know there may be some things that i
need to reflect on and say like i'm not
perfect and i i made mistakes and i
think i can learn and be better from
this situation you know and i'm
certainly not above
saying i'm sorry um we'll be the first
one to say if i hurt somebody's feelings
or made them feel you know what i mean
like you don't want to go it's never my
goal to go into this and do that so if
that is
the case then uh i will i will
definitely look into that and i need to
watch the show and figure it all out
so do you have you know i know you
haven't fully gone back and watch
everything but at this point do you have
any regrets with aligning yourself so
closely with todrick or do you feel like
that played a big part in you winning
this game
well i
feel like i need to have a little bit
more perspective on that i under i do i
am aware that there is some backlash but
to be honest i have not gotten onto my
social media or anything like that so i
i can only speak for myself i can't
speak for anybody else right um i did
try to play the game the best that i
could uh i knew that i needed somebody
who would have a strong social game
because i didn't feel like that would be
my my strength and
um
i may not have made it to the end of
this game if i had played it any
different but doesn't mean that there
weren't mistakes made along the way that
i will have to be accountable for
yeah you know some of the other house
guests have have voiced this but when it
comes to regrets in the house do you
regret how things went down with shayna
um do i regret how things went down with
shayna that's a great question i would
like to see
i still don't know exactly where shayna
was uh in all of it like from my honest
perspective i mean she did agree to a
final four with us in the beginning it
was myself chris kirkpatrick podrick and
her um that was before the live feeds
came up and i don't know if that was
showed or emphasized um she was
definitely you know dabbling on both
sides which is fine because that's how
the game can be played
um
but
uh
gosh i i think i need to go back and and
see where she where her thoughts and
head and everything were really all
about it and everyone else is too you
know i just feel like i'm lacking
perspective here and i don't want to
say something then i'm learning my
lesson it's like you got to kind of
really try to take it all in before you
just dive in and you know say something
that you're not really sure of yeah no i
completely that this must be wild then
everyone has all these questions they
want to ask you we've all seen
everything
i don't know because from my perspective
like i was there and shayna was like i
want to work with you guys and then i
found out she was she was working with
carson and i was like i was blindsided
by that but i think the rest of the
world wasn't and i'm like so i felt like
i was like
well this girl is clearly like playing
both sides and i i don't know i mean is
that are we wrong to pick her out for
that but i think there was maybe more
than just that and that's where it's
kind of like
um you know do i do i owe this woman an
apology is very it's possible you know
that i that i do but it's it is the game
at the end of the day that has no rules
and it just forces you to be under such
a microscope and so much pressure and
it's like
it's difficult to navigate so i did try
my best but i'm only human
what would you say surprised you the
most about playing big brother
um
all of the above i just
have expected anything that happened in
this house i mean really when they say
expect the unexpected that is it
encapsulates the entire experience
and what would you say you've learned
the most about yourself
um what i learned about myself uh
that
that i think my skill set is a fighter
translates over into a lot of other
aspects of my life that i didn't really
realize i mean i i did expect to do well
in the physical competitions but i'm
pretty proud of myself how i did in the
mental competitions i i think the
crossover of just being able to function
under duress and pressure that's what
i've done for the majority of my career
and i do think that it served me well
when it came to the competitions in this
uh in this game
yeah definitely do you think you'll stay
in contact with any of the house guests
absolutely i i honestly wouldn't mind to
stay in contact with all of them and
um you know just i think this was a
unique experience and and we all bonded
in our in our different ways so
yeah absolutely